Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters again. This video is going to be a hypochloridria.
Hypochloridria is a decrease in hydrochloric acid production in the stomach.
You don't probably debose this understood condition of the planet.
Maybe the most common condition on the planet, certainly in the United States.
Not so misunderstood by people that understand health and functional medicine.
It's been well explained through the literature throughout the decades, but it's very misunderstood
in the medical profession and completely mislabeled and misunderstood by the pharmaceutical company
because they make a bloody fortune causing this or perpetuating it, we could say.
So, we're going to dig into this and why we have it and why it's important and why you absolutely need to address it.
The acidity of your stomach, remember acidity is measured on the pH scale of 0 to 14.
7 is neutral. Anything higher than 7, you're getting more alkaline or basic.
Anything lower than 7, you're getting more acidic.
So, pH of your stomach really should be between 1.5 and 2, maybe 1.5 and 1 to 2.5, maybe range.
Anything higher than that, now you're getting a decrease acidity or hypochloridria of your stomach.
Can too much, people think that they have stomach problems because they have too much acid,
well that's just, that is the misnomer. That is the misunderstanding. You do not have too much acid
causing stomach problems. Well, how come would I take an acid that my stomach pain goes away?
You have stomach problems and you burp up hypochloric acid because you're not producing enough
hypochloric acid to digest the food that's in there so that the bolus of food in there is
not getting properly digested, therefore not getting signaling to move into the small intestine.
So, it pushes up into the, past the cardiac sphincter into the esophagus and you get this regurgitation
of acid, and now if you take an acid and it does take that away and you feel so much better,
so that you become addicted to taking antioxidants, which make your problem worse.
You produce less and less stomach acid, you get more and more bowel digestion and all the
disease processes that come along with that which are horrific and you need to know it because
still, you know, cardiovascular disease is the number one cause of death of it at its states
and guess what a common root of that is. This is it, hypochloridria. Hypochloridria leads to
all sorts of problems. One thing you're going to learn it leads to H. Pylori, Helicone,
Bacter Pylori, which is the most common bacterial infection on the planet, according to the
World Health Organization. The number one cause of gastric stomach cancer and in the top five causes
of cardiovascular disease and endothelial disease which is all the arterial sclerosis,
hearty to the arteries, damage to the arteries, all of your cardiovascular diseases.
Are tied, um, uh, uh, greatly tied to H. Pylori overgrowth, which is almost always caused
from hypochlorpidria. That's why it's important. Okay, but also H. Pylori causes a lot of
key answers. We're going to talk about all of that, but you need to keep your stomach acid. It's like,
well, then okay, what do I do? So we'll talk about that a little bit of this. I want to just
show you how you would find this out in the dangers of it. And I have blog posts on how you would
actually treat, um, hypochlorpidria. So, um, make sure you go and check our blog posts on Helicobacter
Pylori, H. Pylori. I'll tell you how to do that. But watch this video first. Okay, so causes,
well, normal aging is a cause. So as we age, our, our, um, cells that make HCl work less efficiently,
just like all our cells can work less efficiency, less efficient. So, uh, we can have normal aging can
cause a decrease HCl. Certainly stress is going to cause decrease HCl. Stress has to do with, um,
stimulating, um, you know, any perceived stress is a sympathetic response. Your autonomic nervous
system is a balance between your sympathetic and your parasympathetic stress is going to increase
your sympathetic tone. And, um, that is going to just, I mean, what you don't, you know what, you
want to bear is chasing you in the woods. You don't need to digest right now. Okay, we don't,
we don't need to digest any food. We need to shut all our energy, our blood flow to our extremities
to run away from this bear. Um, and digestion is not an important thing. That's part of sympathetic
tone is going to shut down digestion. And, um, so it shuts down HCl production, it shuts down
other things too. But, uh, as far as hypochloridory, it's going to shut down HCl production.
Chronic gastritis from other things like alcoholism and, and such post surgical are going to,
are going to decrease, uh, hydrochloric acid production, different autoimmune conditions that I
shared in the, uh, past video. That's why you test in Syrex Array 5. That's one of the things you
test for is intrinsic factor and you test for the cells that make HCl, whether you have antibodies
to those cells in destruction of the cell lining, um, in the stomach where you have much decreased
ability to even make HCl. So you want to test for those infections, uh, bacterial infections,
viral infections, parasitic infections can cause hypochloridria. Uh, I said hypochloridria basically
causes the overgrowth of Hpylori in Hpylori infection. But then in Hpylori infection, then in turn
causes a decreased production of HCl. So it's this negative loop. You need to treat the Hpylori,
you need to supplement for HCl. Biroid conditions can cause a decrease in hydrochloric acid production,
certainly different medications, birth control medications, even n-sense. So you're taking an ad
miller or, or, or Tylenol on a regular basis, you're going to have a decrease in HCl production.
And the worst, absolute worst is the protein pump inhibitors, absolute destruction of HCl production.
It'll make you feel better. Oh my gosh, it's all I care about. It's feeling better. Okay, well,
good luck with that when you had a patent heart attack. I'm not trying to scare you, but when you have
overgrowth, um, hydrochloric, um, Hpylori because of a decreased hydrochloric acid production,
it doesn't just stay in your stomach and cause ulcers. You might never get an ulcer. But it goes
systemically and damages your arteries and damages other things. It is a cause of cancer.
It won't be to scare you, but this is an important thing to deal with. And you don't deal with it
at your own expense. We'll leave it there. Refined carbohydrates, either way too much sugar,
can decrease HCl production. Zinc and thiamine deficiencies can cause that. And this is another
loop. So if you have a decreased HCl production, you can end up with a zinc and other nutrient deficiencies.
Lack of dietary protein, low estrogen. So there's a lot of different causes to this. There's a lot
of different effects too. And this list could be five times this lung. But you're definitely going to
have poor digestion. And I hit that really, really hard in the last video. How important digestion is
from a physiological standpoint. If you're not breaking down your proteins and carbohydrates,
that's what HCl does in the stomach. And you have a bolus of food that's only partially broken down,
going into the small intestine. It puts an enormous amount of stress on the paycreas and on your liver
and on your gallbladder. And they won't keep up. And this goes on over time. And you're going to end up
with other things. This is how it can lead to colon cancer and other more serious things.
Certainly you're going to have malabsorption. You're going to have issues with constipation
diarrhea. All sorts of different dietary issues. It's just going to affect your GI tract horribly
because you're not breaking things down. And how I explained in the last video, if you're not breaking
things down, that you can't absorb things. And then you will damage the gut wall. And then you will
actually allow things to pass in a form that's larger than it should have gotten through the
cell membrane because the barrier has been breached. And that's how you end up developing antibodies
against foods and against things and damaging yourselves. You know you have this inflammatory
process going on. And why am I allergic to all these foods and why is everybody allergic to
gluten down? Why is everybody allergic to dairy down? Why do we have all these allergies?
This is the big part of it, okay? So if you're not digesting, properly digesting the food that
you're putting in your stomach, then you're going to start developing antibodies to these food particles.
If you want a healthier body, you need to start with digestion. It has to start, you know,
from the top down. So hyperchloridory is a huge thing. If people that have health problems,
all they did, remember, this is what I said in another video somewhere, that the most important
supplement to take of anybody that has health problems is probably our clear digest, which has
HCl in it, digestive enzymes in it, and bile salts in it. You know, getting your body to digest that
what you consume, you're going to just improve the health of your gut. I mean, not that you shouldn't
do a whole bunch of other things and investigate other things, but if you won't start here,
you're going to have troubles. HCl also is, protects is your first light in defense against pathogens.
We eat foods that have bacteria in them, right? We eat bacteria, we're touching our hamburger with
our hands that, you know, we have bacteria and viruses and pathogens and, you know, don't think
you're going out to eat some places. You're not picking up parasites. Well, if you have good HCl,
a good pH in your stomach and good, maybe one to two pH level in your stomach, you're going to kill
all that stuff. So you can consume sushi and you don't have to worry about it because your stomach
is going to kill that stuff. You're not going to end up with some sort of passage under paracetic
infection because HCl is your first light in defense against these pathogens and you have a
decrease HCl, you're going to end up with pathogens. You're going to end up with ulcers because what
causes ulcers is Hpylori. So Hpylori is the cause of stomach ulcers, esophageolarsal ulcers,
duodin ulcers. You're going to have reflux issues. Yep, because it's a decreased hydrochloric acid that's
causing reflux that's causing all this extra acid in your stomach. You're going to have
hydrochloric acid. I mean functional hydrochloric acid issues. And please go to our website and watch
the video that I created on how to take care of hydrochloric acid. I created that specifically because
you need to do this on yourself and have somebody do this in your home. You can't just be dependent
upon going to a doctor to do this because a person that has a functional hydrochloric acid issue,
it happens multiple times a day. They need to pull that down to tell that really heals.
This is a problem that I personally had as a hydrochloric acid issue all the way through my childhood
into high school until I went to a car parter that did kadesiology and started working on me with
this and just literally just changed my life in a lot of ways because that really, really helped by
GI issues that I was having. Highly overlooked, even by most functional medicine doctors,
watch my video on how to self-treat and have a friend or partner, self-treacher,
hyalurdea, it will be very helpful for you. Decrease HCL causes dysbiosis, causing
small intestine dysbiosis, larger intestine dysbiosis. Restless legs, anxiety, constipation,
fatigue, everything you can probably think of, signs and symptoms of H-pilory, belching gas
after eating blah, blah, blah, you can look at the slide and you can get anything with it.
And even if somebody says, oh, my friend had a heart attack, it sounds really silly,
but if your friend had a heart attack, they need to get on HCL and digestive enzymes,
not that they should investigate other things and deal with the arterial damage.
And I have a whole series on functional cardiology on our website in a blog format.
So make sure you catch those too. We're really digging to the causes of high blood pressure
and the need to decrease IL-6, etc. It's a whole series of blog posts on that.
But definitely don't overlook supplementing with HCL and digestive enzymes.
How is HCL formed in our body not to get too technical, histology-wise? But I think this piece is
really important just to understand some physiology because dealing with cancer patients, it's not
uncommon that I mentioned this multiple times. It's not uncommon for somebody to say that they're
they're using alkaline water and they think that alkaline water is beneficial for them.
Or they're using sodium bicarbonate in their water. They're taking a table spoon of sodium carb
bicarbonate baking soda every day because they're trying to alkalize their body. Their idea is that
if we can alkalize our body, we're going to be helpful. And there's even books written about how we
need to measure our pH of our saliva and measure our pH of our urine, and that's going to show our
health. Well, I have a blog post on this and I have some multiple videos on this because I wanted
to spell that myth. I just think that's really, really wrong. And it's not understanding physiology.
If you take sodium bicarbonate, you will decrease your stomach pain if you are belching acid,
but you're doing it. It's the same thing as taking tums or taking a PPI. It's not helping your
problem. It's actually hurting you because you're decreasing your HCL production, though you'll
reduce your symptom. You're not solving the problem. You think you're you're understanding medicine
and you think if you just reduce the symptoms, then you solve the problem. That's why we have so much
disease. So we need to search for the cause and figure that out. This diagram here gets in the
depth of how HCL is made. HCL, your stomach parietal cells, the parietal cell that shows
in this diagram, that big yellow block thing there, steals carbon dioxide from the blood, combines
with water to make carbonate or carbonic acid. And it then releases the hydrogen into the stomach.
Lumin were combines with chloride that's taken from the blood to make hydrochloric acid in the
stomach. Lumin. The byproduct of this whole process is bicarbonate ions. Bicarbonate is then put
back into the blood and then distills into the tissues. In what is bicarbonate? Bicarbonate has a
pH of about 12.3. I think that's your alkalized ability. So by you decreasing the alkalinity
of your stomach, you're actually acidifying your tissue. I don't know how to say it any other way.
You're not understanding physiology. If you support the acidity of your stomach and thereby support
the health of the parietal glands ability to make hydrochloric acid in the stomach, you are
alkalizing the tissue because the whole process of making hydrochloric acid puts bicarbonate ions
into the blood that then you have a buffering system in the blood. It won't get too alkaline. So
shuts those into the tissues into the extracellular spaces into the cells. You are in
sense. You are alkalizing the tissue when you are acidifying the stomach. This is really some of
the core issues. If it is a truth that cancer is growing in an acidic environment, then I dispel that
myth by saying cancer creates an acidic environment because it's highly metabolic and it's giving
up a lot of waste which is acidic. You need to alkalize it. How do you do it? You support the
production of H cell in your stomach. You don't alkalize your stomach because when you support the
process of H cell production in your stomach, you are alkalizing, giving alkaline tissue bicarbonate
to the blood which then goes to the tissues in your alkalizing the tissues. Okay? So let's throw that
myth out. So hydrochloric hypochloridria diseases that are associated with diabetes childhood asthma
really common disease associated with hypochloridria thyroid dysfunction tied to hypochloridria skin
conditions, skin conditions even acne can be tied to hypochloridria. Certainly other skin conditions
are tied to helical vector pylori, which is tied to hypochloridria. Osteoporosis is hypochloridria
issue. Part of the osteoporosis and part of the systemic issues with hypochloridria, I think have
to do with the lack of production of alkalizing bicarbonate because if you're not producing the bicarbonate
through making H cell you have to steal calcium from the blood or from the bone to buffer the
blood. Understand you have a buffering system in your body and you will maintain a pH of your blood
of 7.35 I think it is or you'll die so you will maintain that. Okay? The only time it won't be that
is near death and you will get that buffering system in the blood either through the production
of HCL spilling bicarbonated in the blood or you'll steal calcium from the bones. You have to get
a buffer. You have to get a pH buffer and your calcium is a pH buffer so you'll steal calcium
from the bones. You'll end up with osteoporosis. Obviously chronic gastritis is a piece to that too.
We could go out and on. Hpylora is the worst piece of the hypochloridria puzzle. I've
hounded on that a little bit now. I'm going to refer you to this blog post. I just did a screenshot
of our website. Just search for helico by pylora, information and care in our little search bar
there. You'll pull up a blog post and it'll explain some of the pathway that's associated with it.
We'll touch out a little bit more in this video as I go here because I think it's so so important.
Different physical exam findings listed. Adult acne is tied to decreased HCL production,
dilated capillaries and the nose and face. That is tied to alcoholism too but it's also tied to
somebody could have that when they don't even drink. It's tied to decreased Hpylora, skin
conditions dealing with dandruff and flaky skin, soft pore growth of fingernails, brittle and
spitting splitting nails, white spots on the nails. That's typically thought of as zinc deficiency
but when you have a decreased hydrochloric acid production you won't absorb zinc so even if you're
taking zinc you're going to have poor absorption of zinc and you're still going to have a functional
deficiency in the signs thereof. Functional blood chemistry analysis patterns. You're going to have
possible hypochloroetry as possible if you look and I talked about this in the last video but if
you look at it in the person has an increased globulent level and yet a normal or decreased total protein
and or albumin. And hypochloroetry is even more probable if globulent levels are increased along
with an increased bun, blood urea, nitrogen, a decreased or a normal total protein and or albumin
and or decreased serum phosphorous. So those are the things that you look at in a blood chemistry
panel to confirm hypochloroetry but 95% of the time you're going to diagnose it based upon the
person's symptoms. So and you and honestly you know I have all my family members taking a HCL and
digestive enzyme just because it is just it's just everybody has it. I mean because of our diet why
does everybody have it? Well because you're eating chemicals and additives and colorings and
flavorings and pesticides and herbicides and glyphosate and all these things that damage the cell,
damage that parietal cell of the stomach to produce it. So we're damaging that cell you need to
take some burden off the cell by adding HCL to your diet when you eat food so that that cell can
recover and start producing so you can alkalize your blood and your tissue and digest your food.
So you just need to. Other patterns in blood chemistry and in this can be all over the place so
you can't go by all of these. In imbalance it can be either higher or gastrin, your MCV and MCH know
those are red blood cell patterns, your mean corpuscular volume and your mean corpuscular hemoglobin
are increased typically with anemia they're going to be different types of anemia with anemia lots
when we see with cancer patients anemia of chronic disease they're going to be decreased but with
other anemias they can be increased. And it's because you need HCL to to help you absorb
iodine help you utilize iodine so you have abnormal ferritid levels and that's going to throw
the MCV and MCH off a decreased or normal calcium decreased iodine back to the need for HCL in order
to absorb iodine a decreased CO2 and increased anion gap and a decreased alkaline phosphatase those
are some of the things you can see not the exact patterns but some of the things you can see in the
blood work. Hpilora again the worst issue with with the decreased hydrochloric acid production it
suppresses the prion cells so if you you know already you know you already have decreased HCL because
of your diet and now you have overgrowth of Hpilora. Hpilora in turn suppresses the prion cells production
of HCL and then you end up with iron malabsorption B12, malabsorption, calcium malabsorption
you end up with SIBO you end up with microbiome decrease microbiome diversity and then it'll digest
a malabsorption syndrome in the gut. You have damaged vascular endothelial this is one of the most
damaged pieces of it I said it is in the listed in the top five cause of cardiovascular
cerebrovascular risks. You have antibody molecular mimicry I talk about this a little bit in the
autoimmune course. It's a molecular Hpilora is a molecular mimic to your prion cells causing auto
immunity that's why we test for that in the Syrex array five tests to see if you have actually
antibodies to the prion cells we're talking about the prion cells in the stomach that make HCL
worst case scenario and you have other gastric lighting cells causing gastritis you could have
a molecular mimicry to the pancreas and end up with type 1 diabetes. You say oh my gosh so my
decrease HCL could have caused all these things yes yes it could have that's why you know the more
you can learn for your kids even if you're in your 40s or 50s or you're just learning this stuff
well the more you can learn for your kids and grandkids and help them prevent some of these issues
that we've gone through that's why you're learning right so don't stop learning you don't think
you're just learning for yourself you're learning to help share this stuff to other people hopefully
you're getting this out right there's different patterns I'm not going to go through all these patterns
of what you'll see with Hpilora because our software really pulls that out and you'll see if we put
your blood work your CBC and complete metabolic panel in our software that it'll actually say that
this is a possible pattern to look for because it is so prominent remember HCL helical
factor pylora according to the World Health Organization is the number one bacteria bacterial infection
worldwide so just because you haven't heard of it you know doesn't mean that you know it's not there
it's there so there's functional tests to test for this there's blood tests to measure antibodies
not real effective because it tests for a IgA and IgG antibodies which could be passed exposure the
urea brach test is is a pretty accurate test but you can miss it in that the probably the most accurate
is a stool antigen test and you know a complete stool diagnostic test would be probably the easiest
way to do it but again you know I actually in myself I just treat it constantly so I take burberry
and in the blog post I talk about different ways that you treat it I take burberry and other
fairly regularly they don't take it daily but I take it regularly because that is you know burberry
and garlic are probably your best killers of H pylora these heart diseases in our family and again
what's the one of the top causes of heart disease H pylora so you're just gonna assume you have it
it's ubiquitous it's everywhere according to the World Health Organization if you diagnose a person
with H pylora you treat them with an antibiotic which I don't necessarily recommend unless it's
an acute stage and you are seriously sick but you'd want to treat it from a natural perspective on
a regular basis but if this person comes it is retested 30 days later and they have it again then you
have to treat them their whole family include their family pets because it's ubiquitous you're gonna
just pick this up everywhere you it's not whether you're gonna be exposed to it it's whether you have
good HCl production so you'll kill it remember one of the main reasons for HCl is to kill pathogens
that you're exposed to orally so I hit that pretty hard so it's just because it's so gosh darn important
so keep studying you know know that you're studying not just for yourself but for others your family
people you love tell people the truth that's what we're here for to just get this truth out there share
this video share your knowledge with as many people as you can don't let them love love you guys
and pray for you and we'll see you at the next video